how are you Peter hey rich I'm doing
well thanks a lot you bet so what do you
think is the storyline of Super Bowl 50
- man I you know I listen to all of
yours okay and I I really think you know
this is just my opinion that Marais D
has done so much it would be hard for me
no matter what happens in this game to
not think he's the best quarterback of
all time I mean I I had you know in for
much of my NFL coverage career much my
you know time covering the NFL having
done a lot of research in the 90s to
write a book about pro football history
I kind of had a soft spot for Otto
Graham who in the ten years he played
played in the championship game of his
league all 10 years won seven titles and
also one for passing championships so it
would be hard for anybody to beat that
but I think that Brady has beaten it the
longevity is you know unheard of the
fact that he basically has been at or
near the top of his game in his 17th
year as a starting quarterback in the
NFL and the fact that he's going to win
the MVP most likely in his 17th year is
a starting quarterback I can't imagine
if he loses 51 to 3 in this game why I
still wouldn't think he's the best
quarterback of all time so and and I
think rich this this game and this
season really cements the legacy of
Belichick and Brady is the best
quarterback coach combination without
any question and add Bob crafter that
you know is the best combination in NFL
history we we've always sort of thought
of or at least I have Eddie DeBartolo
Bill Walsh Joe Montana is the gold
standard of owner coach quarterback
trio but rich they lasted ten years
together Kraft Belichick and Brady have
lasted 18 years 17 years with Brady
starting so it's it's one of the most
incredible stories I think any of us
will ever see not just in football but
in sports
that said though Peter everyone that I
talked to says that there will be a
meeting once this game is over win or
lose amongst Brady Belichick and Kraft
to hash something out what what do you
think that hashing out actually is and
how do you think that's gonna manifest
itself done well I think what we know
right now is that you know Bob Kraft is
going to own the Patriots in 2018 what
we also know is that barring the
surprise of the century Tom Brady is
going to play quarterback for the
Patriots in 2018 we all assume that Bill
Belichick is going to coach the Patriots
in 2018 I can't imagine that he would be
opening the door as wide as he is for
format patricia josh mcdaniels
and perhaps i mean he certainly allowed
brian flores who's going to be his
defensive coordinator now that arizona's
has filled its coaching vacancy with
Steve Wilkes but you know I just it's
hard for me to imagine that Belichick
would simply walk away after having sort
of emptied the cupboard so I still think
they'll all be back together and what
they'll talk about rich
I mean look I've had this discussion
quite a few times with people inside the
Patriots since the web Seth Wickersham
story came out which the Patriots have
vocally and largely denied and which I
just say well okay let's let's just see
time will tell
my feeling is that Seth is obviously a
reliable reporter and in my opinion
there's something to this what exactly
it is I'll be honest with you I just
don't know
I've asked I've looked around I've put
out the old sniffers and I don't know
the answer to it but I do think that and
again this is not unnatural
you tell me where has an owner a coach
and a quarterback work together ever
together in football in such an
emotional draining game as football at
the highest level of football when of
you work together for 18 years and and
everybody walks out in in kumbaya spirit
there's got to be some issues between
you know the three most powerful people
in the organization so we'll find out
what they are but it certainly hasn't
stopped them from accomplishing the
greatness that they have and I'm sure
again this is gonna be brought up media
day etc etc throughout the week and
it'll be moving on to Philadelphia Peter
King here on the Rich Eisen show what
what intrigued you about the
Philadelphia Story Peter I think the
fact that rich if you watch the the
Oakland game on Christmas night Oakland
Philadelphia and then the Dallas game
the next week when when Philadelphia's
first unit was in there for most of the
first half and then you watched the
Atlanta playoff game I'll tell you what
I saw in all that and I saw a team that
was protecting the quarterback that was
making sure that the quarterback didn't
throw the ball away take too many
chances
etc and I think this team had a
protective cloak over Nick Foles and
then I think this past Sunday is Chris
Long said to me after the game hey you
know with Nick Foles right now the
preseason is over in other words he
hadn't played football in essence you
know for four months and then all of a
sudden he's thrown into the fire it's
five degrees outside and you know and
probably pretty tough deal for him but
but having said all that at this point
as we think about it right at this point
you know we saw a different game plan
with Philadelphia on Sunday Nick Foles
threw the ball downfield me threw it
down field effectively and so right now
the New England Patriots when Matt
Patricia looks at this tape he's going
to say ok and he's going to tell Devin
McCourty and everybody in the
secondary's gonna tell him here we got
to defend the whole field now this is
not a digging dunk passing game anymore
and that's going to make it harder for
the Patriots so I think the fact my most
interesting story on the Eagles is that
now they're not a team that is going to
shy away from letting Nick Foles try to
win the game yeah they're not going to
take a knee with two timeouts and 55
seconds left in the first
that's right and you know again no so
what's the one thing you think that
Belichick is gonna and Patricia is going
to try and take away the quintessential
that's what they yeah that's what they
do I don't think I don't really think
there is one there isn't mean normally I
would have said you know because you saw
that what they did with Leonard
fournette is that they really jammed up
the box and tried to make tried to make
bortles beat and and in part we can sit
here and say see bortles couldn't beat
him but did he really have much of a
chance to beat him and I will always
maintain that the throw he made to Dede
Westbrook that Stephon Gilmore made the
biggest play that he will ever make in
his NFL career in his football career in
his life as an athlete one of the great
plays ever on the top level of football
that that that was that was a very good
throw but it wasn't a great throw and I
think that that throw showed me a
crucial crucial throw showed me that if
I'm Doug Marrone I'm thinking I should
have put the ball in bortles hands more
in the fourth quarter to try to keep the
ball away from the Patriots that's what
the Jaguars should regret about this
game well to me that Gilmore play was
certainly when we've been spending the
whole week prior to the game talking
about Coughlin's image Coughlin's
presence and also Coughlin secret sauce
in games against the Patriots that that
would have been the Tyree or man
a moment of the game for Jacksonville
and Gilmore swatted it away out have
been it right there Peter
I agree rich and I in my opinion I think
that's a really really good comparison
because you know that game right there
there that play right there if he misses
that ball there's a very good chance the
DD res per catch is it and even if he
somehow come short of score touchdown
you know the Jaguars you know are in
position at that point to even run a
little bit of clock away and and score
and be a very good position to score and
leave the Patriots nothing left so I'm
not saying the game would have been over
if he could if Gilmore doesn't make that
play but it would have been darn close
last minute I have for you Peter is give
me the name of somebody who's missed at
the Pro Football Hall of Fame last
couple years last long time of years
that you're hearing this year might have
the groundswell to finally get in oh I'm
always wrong about it rich okay him I'm
always wrong sometimes all are closest
to a story you don't really know but I
walked out of there last year and on
Sunday morning at the hotel in Houston I
ran into Tony Boselli I was going down
to the Starbucks to get a coffee and do
some work on Sunday morning before going
over to the game and there was the celli
who had the same ideas me he was getting
coffee and I said some Tony I'm just
gonna tell you this yesterday was an
extremely encouraging day for you and I
also believe for John Lynch but but
probably more for Boselli in this way
okay so Boselli played at the absolute
top level of football for six seasons
and a little bit more than that but the
absolute highest level shutout Derrick
Thomas shut out some of the great pass
rushers of his day and he has not gotten
in the Hall because many people have
said well his career wasn't long enough
well he was at least as good and maybe
probably better for six years than
Terrell Davis was for four even though
Davis was
was unbelievable for three in those
years and extremely good for a fourth
but now the Terrell Davis has made the
Hall of Fame you know to me that opens
the door wide for Tony Vasilis Peter
love our chats look forward to seeing
you out in Minnesota sounds great thank
you
you bet that's Peter King @s i
underscore Peter King the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience